tja willkommen zur aktuellen Vorlesung
heute steht wie immer das begriffsnetz
an erster Stelle und auch da wurde ich
darauf hingewiesen dass es hier noch ein
bisschen Unklarheiten gab im linken
unteren Eck sie wissen natürlich sofort
welcher Bereich dabei aufgerufen wird
links unten was ist da Freiheit genau
oder eben auch diese Debatte um die
Freiheit und zwar ging es um diese
Verhältnisse der termination
Notwendigkeit in Differenz hatte ich
dann und dann haben wir mal eine
Tutorien zu Recht gesagt da ist noch ein
andere Begriff in diesem Kontext wichtig
erstmal in Differenz sie sehen ich habe
ja ein verbindungspfeil gemacht ich
mache ihn noch mal hin der geht so
Willkür also das was nur Indifferenz
gleichgültig ohne überwiegende Gründe
getan wird das könnte man Indifferenz
nehmen und jetzt gibt's noch einen
anderen Begriff den füge ich noch hinzu
das ist der in der terminismus den habe
ich jetzt häufig mit Indifferenz
gleichgesetzt aber da kann man strenge
noch ein bisschen genauer unterscheiden
in der terminismus heißt einfach dass
eine Handlung oder unser Wille einfach
nicht bestimmt ist das ist nicht genau
dasselbe wie Indifferenz aber ziemlich
ähnlich
hier geht es um interterminismus ist der
Gegenbegriff zu der thermitismus während
Indifferenz sich stärker auf Willkür
bezieht wenn man bestimmte Gründe nicht
abwägen will sondern einfach sagt ist
mir alles egal ich werfe jetzt mal die
Münze wobei auch da habe ich ja
eigentlich irgendwie wieder einen Grund
mit einbezogen haben wir gesehen
kompatibilismus inkompatibilismus in
kompatibilismus kann man unterscheiden
harten Determinismus und den die
batterianismus und jetzt gibt es noch
interessante Beziehung nämlich zwischen
Indeterminismus und lieber Taria
das heißt in wenn man ein
Indeterminismus vertritt dann kann man
sehr gut auch eine libertarianische
Position
beziehen oder vertreten weil die ja
voraussetzt dass der Determinismus
falsch ist das heißt dann könnte ich ein
Indeterminismus vertreten wir haben
einmal hier gemeinsam eine solche
mögliche klausurfrage diskutiert und da
haben wir gesehen das Problem des in der
terminismus ist ja dass der irgendwie
auch nicht Freiheit richtig erklärt weil
wenn es unbestimmt ist dann habe ich
auch irgendwie gar keine guten Gründe
wie die Handlung verständlich machen
muss ja der Vorteil ist natürlich dass
ich nicht determiniert bin aber man hat
damit auch nicht so viel gewonnen also
ein libertarianismus muss dieses Problem
der Indifferenz oder das in der
terminismus irgendwie berücksichtigen
und uns trotzdem eine Antwort darauf
geben wie wir die Handlung noch
verstehen können wenn sie nicht hart der
terminiert ist ne also da wollte ich
noch ein bisschen weiter vernetzen das
dann kann man ein bisschen weitergehen
wir sind jetzt nicht mehr links unten
sondern unsere Debatte vollzieht sich
jetzt zum Ende des Semesters rechts
unten in diesem Schema wir hatten die
Neid diskutiert und heute soll es noch
mal um das Thema Gerechtigkeit gehen und
dann verstärkt um das Gute bevor es dann
in der nächsten Sitzung über das Thema
des Bösen gehen wird das ist mein
persönliches Lieblingsthema oben rechts
mache ich noch mal den Link rein zu
meiner zu meinem Interview über True
Crime Serien warum das uns fasziniert
dieses Böse im Fernsehen
jetzt möchte ich noch einen kleinen
Nachtrag geben zu schon rolls auch da
werden wir in den Tutorien wenn sie
hingehen können Sie gerne einen kurzen
Text nämlich eben Gerechtigkeit als
fernes das ist auch ein Titel eines
Aufsatzes von ihm eines kleineren
Beitrags nicht nur eines Buches da
können Sie den Text mal gemeinsam im
Tutorium auch ein bisschen diskutieren
der ist nämlich sehr gut verständlich
und macht die Sache auch noch ein
bisschen klarer
so sei der gute Mann aus das ist sein
wichtigstes Werk ethere of Justice
wirklich das wer zur politischen
Philosophie generell der zweiten Hälfte
des 20 Jahrhunderts und dann hier dieser
neuere Band
justice ist fairings und jetzt möchte
ich Ihnen noch ein bisschen was Vorlesen
aus diesem Aufsatz über
fernetz er sagt nämlich es zeigt sich
dass der Begriff der Fairness der sich
auf den richtigen Umgang von Personen
untereinander bezieht die miteinander
kooperieren oder gegeneinander
konkurrieren
für Gerechtigkeit grundlegend ist wenn
man von fairen Spielen faire Wettbewerb
oder fairen Verhandlungen spricht die
fairnessfrage stellt sich dann wenn
freie Personen die keine Autorität
übereinander haben jetzt kommt die fett
gedruckte von mir Passagen sich in einer
gemeinsamen Aktivität engagieren und
untereinander die Regeln festlegen oder
anerkennen die sie definieren und die
jeweiligen Anteile an ihren Vorteilen
und Lasten bestimmen
eine Praxis für den Parteien ganz
herkommen wenn keine von ihnen den
Eindruck hat dass sie selbst oder eine
andere Person Parteien durch die
Teilnahme an ihr ausgenutzt oder
gezwungen wird
Ansprüchen nachzugeben die sie nicht für
berechtigt hält
ich glaube bis dahin können wir es mal
lassen also er wird da sehr konkret er
geht hier auch auf diesen Wettbewerb ein
wir haben schon festgestellt Fairness
gibt es häufig in Konkurrenzsituationen
ja auch spielen Fußballspiel Fairplay
also das ist so ein bisschen Ansatzpunkt
wir haben auch darüber diskutiert wie
vielleicht dieser fairnessansatz
problematisch sein kann ja aber ganz
wichtig ist dass man hier auch etwas
anerkennt und zwar gemeinsam also
gemeinsam wird etwas anerkannt und ja
man wichtigen Begriff Anerkennung der
steht im Kontrast zum Begriff des
missgünstigendes wie wir ihn der letzten
Sitzung diskutiert haben also das
Problem des leidet ist das schlechten
leidest des Bösen leid das sage immer
das missgünstigen Neid ist ist das dass
ihm Neid wir nichts anerkennen wir
wollen nicht anerkennen die Leistung
eine andere Person dass sie es verdient
hat das heißt der Neid der hat
eigentlich eine Struktur die dieser
diesen Fairness Charakter der
Anerkennung gerade zuwider ist das sieht
man zum Beispiel als auch in sportlichen
Kontexten bin ich jetzt zwei Jahre lang
auf den Konstanz Halbmarathon trainiert
habe und ein guter Freund von mir nur
zwei Wochen und den Konstanz halt
Marathon schneller läuft als ich dann
gebietet ist die Fairness sofern er sich
nicht gedruckt hat
dass ich ihm dazu gratuliere dass ich
seine Leistung anerkenne und nicht nach
Gründen suche warum er jetzt obwohl er
sich nur zwei Wochen darauf vorbereitet
hat besser war als ich ja also natürlich
kann man jetzt solche Kontexte der
sportliche fairn ist nicht auf alle
Gerechtigkeitsfragen übertragen da würde
ich auch zustimmen aber es ist ein
Schlüssel zum Begriff der Gerechtigkeit
wenn man hier von Gedanken der
Anerkennung ausgeht der
gleichberechtigten Anerkennung also
Gerechtigkeit wird auch über Anerkennung
bestimmt und Anerkennung ist ein
gewaltiges Thema was in ganz
verschiedenen anderen Kontexten der
Sozialphilosophie vorkommt unter anderem
auch von Georg Wilhelm Friedrich Hegel
auch der hat eine Theorie der
Anerkennung entworfen die sogar
geschichtliche Dimension hat also nicht
nur jetzt ob ich Leistung eine Person
anerkennen sondern er spricht von einem
Kampf um Anerkennung das ist also ganz
wichtiges Prinzip die natürlich muss die
gerechtfertigt sein ich kann nur das
anerkennen was anerkennenswert ist ich
kann keine Leistung anerkennen wenn ein
guter Freund von mir sich gedopt hat und
dadurch ein unfairen Vorteil beim
Konstanz Halbmarathon hatte das kann ich
nicht anerkennen ich muss davon ausgehen
dass es hier mit rechten Dingen zuging
und dann bin ich ihm aber auch die
Anerkennung schuldig und der Neid soll
nicht sein und jetzt spricht er hier von
Gerechtigkeit wir hatten es nämlich
schon mal kurz der Vorlesung er spricht
von Gerechtigkeit als trugend sozialer
Institution also Gerechtigkeit wird
häufig in der Antike als eine
kardinaltugen im Kontext von anderen
Tugenden diskutiert willkommen heute
noch mal auf das Thema Tugend wenn es um
das gute bei aristotel ist geht also
Tugenden hängen immer auch mit dem guten
zusammen Gerechtigkeit ist eine
kardinaltugen es gibt nur andere Tugend
Besonnenheit Tapferkeit
Klugheit solche Dinge die Gerechtigkeit
ist vielleicht sogar die wichtigste er
spricht auch von Praktiken die
Prinzipien der Gerechtigkeit werden so
aufgefasst dass sie
Einschränkungen im Hinblick darauf
formulieren wie Praktiken Position und
Funktionen definieren und wie sie ihnen
einfach macht Befugnisse und
Verantwortlichkeiten
Recht und Pflichten zuweisen dürfen an
keiner Stelle sagte behandle ich in
folgengerechtigkeit als eine Tugend von
einzelnen Handlungen oder Personen er
hat also kein individualistischen Blick
drauf er sagt es ist wichtig diese
verschiedenen Träger der Gerechtigkeit
voneinander zu unterscheiden also
gerecht kann ganz verschieden sein nicht
nur meine Handlung dass ich meinem
Freund da gratuliere zu seinem
erfolgreichen
Marathon
da die Bedeutung des Begriffs in Bezug
darauf variiert ob er auf Praktiken
einzelne Handlungen oder Personen
angewendet wird diese Bedeutung sind
tatsächlich dann das verbunden jedoch
sind sie nicht identisch wir können also
nicht nur gerechte Handlungen gerechte
Personen sondern was gibt es noch es
gibt noch gerechte Institutionen zum
Beispiel verlangt man auch dass die
Universität eine gerechte Institutionen
es gibt vielleicht gerechte Staaten es
gibt auch gerechte kollektive Person da
kommt wieder unser Begriff der
kollektiven Person spielt und jetzt sagt
er die Konzeption der Gerechtigkeit die
er entwickeln möchte kann in Form von
zwei Prinzipien dargestellt werden
erstens hat jede Person die an einer
Praxis beteiligt oder von den betroffen
ist ein gleiches Recht auf die
weitreichende Freiheit die ihrerseits
mit derselben Freiheit für alle
vereinbar ist und zweitens sind die
Ungleichheiten will natürlich
also nicht beabsichtigt zur zufällig es
sei denn dass man vernünftigerweise
erwarten kann dass es sich zu jedermanns
Vorteil auswirken
also Ungleichheit darf nur dann sein
willentlich intentional beabsichtigt
wenn sie zum Vorteil von allen dienen
das kann schon manchmal sein dass man
Ungleichheiten braucht um für alle den
größten Vorteil zu erreichen dabei wird
vorausgesetzt dass die Position und
Funktion mit denen sie die
Ungleichheiten verbunden sind oder durch
diese herbeigeführt werden allen offen
stehen diese Prinzipien drücken
Gerechtigkeit als ein Komplex von drei
Ideen aus nämlich Freiheit Gleichheit
und Belohnung von Leistung die zum
Gemeinwohl beitragen sie sehen hier das
Gemeinwohl da steckt schon so ein
bisschen der Gedanke des Utilitarismus
im Hintergrund da geben heute noch mal
einen drauf ein gut ist das was die
meisten Nutzen mit sich bringt aber so
einfach ist es nicht dass man jetzt
schon rolls Theorie als
utilitaristisch bezeichnet da ich gehe
noch ein bisschen weiter und dann
diskutier mal kurz rüber wie sie diesen
Gerechtigkeitsbegriff finden
ich hatte schon angedeutet der
Gerechtigkeitsbegriff kann sich auf ganz
Verschiedenes beziehen nicht nur auf
individuelle Handlung oder individuelle
Personen sagt der Begriff Person ist
abhängig von den jeweiligen Umständen
verschieden aufzufassen beim manchen
Gelegenheit bezeichnet der menschliche
Individuen das sind also individuelle
Personen bei anderen kann er sich jedoch
etwa auf Nationen Provinzen
Wirtschaftsunternehmen Kirche oder
Mannschaften beziehen man kann zum
Beispiel sagen die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft im Fußball hat fair
gespielt da war Gerechtigkeit drin fair
Player überhaupt drin das ist natürlich
ein
sozialer Gerechtigkeit sind jetzt im
engeren Sinne aber im Sinne des Pferdes
kann man das auch auf Mannschaften
beziehen natürlich sind
Wirtschaftsunternehmen wie er
gefragt gerecht zu sein aber Nation
natürlich auch soziale Institutionen
Grundsätzen die Prinzipien der
Gerechtigkeit gilt alle diese Fälle
obwohl der der menschlichen und
Individuum also gerechte Personen eine
gewisse logische Priorität hat warum
logische Priorität weil natürlich auch
die anderen kollektiven gerechten
Personen letztendlich aus individuellen
Personen zusammengesetzt sind ja da
steht natürlich immer individuelle
Person dahinter verbunden mit joint
commitment sie nennen sich noch an diese
Sitzung für dieses joint commitment
hatten diese gemeinsame Intention die
muss gebildet werden aber zugrunde
liegen kollektiven Personen immer
individuell so natürlich auch noch
Vereinbarungen sonstiges Strukturen
rechtliche Art
genau also das ist mir auch noch wichtig
dann hatten wir hier auf das
differenzprinzip Bezug genommen da geht
es halt immer darum
wie ist das Verhältnis zu den am
wenigsten begünstigsten er sagt geht man
von den Institutionen aus bis sie von
der gleichen Freiheit für alle und der
fairen Chancengleichheit gefordert
werden wo sind die besseren Aussichten
der begünstigten genau dann gerecht wenn
sie zu Verbesserung der Aussichten die
am wenigsten begünstigsten Mitglieder
der Gesellschaft beitragen also immer
diese Differenz die am meisten und der
am wenigsten die günstigsten intuitiv
ist Gedanke ist der dass die
Gesellschaftsordnung nur dann günstigere
Aussichten für die bevorzugte einrichten
und sichern da wenn das denn weniger
begünstigten zum Vorteil gereicht ist es
also zurückgebunden anders Interesse die
am wenigsten begünstigten das heißt die
werden nicht außer Acht gelassen die
werden nicht einfach ausgeblendet so
dass man sagt auch auf die kommt doch
gar nicht an wir konzentrieren uns nur
auf dass es denen die schon begünstigt
sind besser geht nein das Interesse oder
die Begünstigung der mehrbegünstigten
wird rückgebunden abhängig gemacht von
dem Zustand die am wenigsten begrüßt
werden sozial und wirtschaftliche
Ungleichheiten sagt er weiter sind so zu
regeln dass sie den am wenigsten
begünstigten die bestmöglichen
Aussichten bringen
bis dahin möchte ich noch mal diese
Rückmeldung die diese
Rückblick geben oft und jetzt möchte ich
mit Ihnen noch kurz diskutieren wo die
Probleme vielleicht auch seine Theorie
liegen können
ja jetzt machen wir weiter nachdem wir
dieses
Gerechtigkeitsprinzip und das
differenzprinzip von John walls hier
sehr kontrovers diskutiert haben gehen
wir weiter auf den Begriff des Guten sie
sehen hier schon Titel normativer
Begriff in unseren begriffsnetz wissen
sie natürlich sofort wo Normativität ist
rechts unten ist ja klar und
will ich noch mal so drei Paradigmen
also drei wichtige Positionen zur Frage
was gut ist Ihnen vorstellen das mache
ich jetzt aber nicht in jeder
ausführlichkeiten alle Ausführlichkeit
weil es ja noch die andere Vorlesung
gibt über Moralphilosophie und das würde
jetzt zu sehr reinspringen ich möchte
jetzt hier vor allem auf den gibt es
guten reflektieren
Utilitarismus ganz kurz gesagt gut ist
das was die meisten Menschen nützt und
Nutzen bringt den größten Nutzen bringt
er ist natürlich einiges wage was ist
nützen und nutzen das ist darunter zu
verstehen gibt sie die Ontologie das ist
die pflichtig Immanuel kann dies ein
Vertreter davon gut sind diejenigen
Maximen die sich vernünftig
verallgemeinern lassen und dann haben
wir noch die Tugend Ethik da steht alles
tot ist dafür gut sind tugendhafte
Handlungen wir müssen das jetzt genau
kurz noch erörtern anhand von
selektiven natürlich
Textbeispiel hier hatte ich Ihnen eine
Übersicht gegeben als es immer hängt
immer davon ab wo setzen wir an wenn wir
das Gute bestimmen wollen oder natürlich
auch das Gericht sie können das analog
auch fürs Gerichte sich überlegen
setzen wir an der Gesellschaft an an
Institutionen oder gehen wir von
Handlungen aus oder gehen wir sogar noch
davon aus was vor den Handlungen steht
nämlich die Motivation die Subjektivität
die Gründe und je nachdem wo wir
ansetzen erhalten und einmal die
deontologie ist jetzt hier in der
Motivation an oder an diese
Utilitarismus der eher auf die
Konsequenzen schaut ähm ich möchte jetzt
immer von John Stewart will einem der
wichtigsten Vertreter des unter die
Terrorismus hat auch ein Buch
geschrieben
Tutorium vielleicht behandelt er sagt
die Auffassung für die die Nützlichkeit
oder das Prinzip des größten Glücks die
Grundlage der Moralist besagt das
Handlung
so weit und dem Maße moralisch richtig
ich füge dazu das heißt gut woran es gut
sind als sie die Tendenz haben Glück zu
befördern und insoweit moralisch falsch
ich füge hinzu war nicht böse als sie
den Tendenz haben das Gegenteil von
Glück zu bewirkt unter Glück ist dabei
Lust und das frei sein
unter Unglück das Fehlen von Los
verstanden
ja jetzt kann man sie natürlich fragen
was ist jetzt hier unter Lust und Glück
zu verstehen ein Einwand den sie
natürlich sofort bringen würden ist Lust
zum Glück ist doch subjektiv ich kann
doch gar nicht wirklich mit solchen
Werten kalkulieren und danach irgendwie
eine Handlung bemessen weil für die eine
Person ist dasjenige Lust lustvoll was
für die andere Person gerade nicht
lustvoll ist so kann man nie auf eine
objektive Theorie des gute wenn wir an
so Wagen Begriffen wie Glück oder Lust
ansetzen sind doch bloß subjektive
Begriffe Moral setzt aber doch voraus
dass wir objektiv sagen was gut ist und
nicht nur was für die eine Person
angenehm und für die andere unangenehm
ist das kann diese Sache sein will war
natürlich ein bedeutender der so schnell
jetzt nicht zu kritisieren ist dann
müssen wir er sein darauf haben sie auch
hingewiesen Fan ist gegenüber der
philosophischen Tradition sein auch alle
Kritik behalten
nämlich die Menschen haben höhere
Fähigkeiten als justierische Gelüste und
Vermögen sobald sie sich diese einmal
bewusst geworden sind nur darin ihr
Glück zu sehen worin deren Betätigung
eingeschlossen ist also auf die Kritik
die naheliegende Kritik Glück und Lust
ist doch subjektiv und da habe ich doch
genau dieselbe Lust wie irgendwie ein
bloßes Tier immer nur die ganze Zeit was
essen
ich weiß nicht was können sich überlegen
irgendwas ungesundes Süßes oder salziges
die ganze Zeit nur
Pommes essen es würden doch am liebsten
auch Mäuse essen lieber Schokolade als
Käse das wissen sie die ganze Zeit
Schokolade essen daraus beziehe ich mein
Glück eine Gesellschaft die voller
Schokolade Tafeln bis jeden Tag bekommen
sie drei Kilo Schokolade kostenlos bitte
damit die Welt besser nein
warum nicht warum weil wir alle Karies
bekommen und dann freut sich nur der
Zahnarzt
weiteres Zitat die Anerkennung der
Tatsache dass einige Arten der Freude
wünschenswerte und wertvoller sind als
andere ist mit dem Nützlichkeitsprinzip
das ist natürlich der Utilitarismus
größtes Glück für die meisten das ist
Nützlichkeitsprinzip durch das vereinbar
ist wäre unsinnig anzunehmen dass der
Wert eine Freude
ausschließlich von der Quantität
abhängen sollte wo doch in der Wert
Bestimmung aller anderen Dingen neben
der Qualität auch die Qualität
Berücksichtigung also am Ende macht hier
John Stewart Mill gar keine Theorie des
Glücks oder der Lust oder der Freude
sondern er macht eigentlich eine Theorie
des Wertes ja wir müssen auch auf den
Begriff des Wertes eingehen was hat ein
Wert und nur dasjenige was die Werte
vergrößert und Werte sagt wir setzen
epistemisch also Erkenntnis theoretisch
höhere Fähigkeiten voraus die überhaupt
diese Werte als Werte erkennen und
wertschätzen können oder auch anerkennen
können also kurz gesagt er billigt uns
zu uns menschlichen Personen dass wir im
systemische Vermögen haben höhere
Fähigkeiten mit denen wir kennen können
das ist besser ist wenn wir alle
Philosophie studieren oder uns auf
Youtube den auf silokast auf der
filocast App den Quiz dass wir das Quiz
machen zu dieser Vorlesung als das wir
stattdessen zwei Tafeln Schokolade
Essen warum weil
das erfolgreiche Lösen des Quizes auf
filocast viel mehr geistige Lust
produziert als das Verzehren von zwei
Tafeln Schokolade warum weil wir danach
kein Völlegefühl haben
geistige Lust Befriedigung macht nicht
träge sondern inspiriert während zu viel
Schokolade essen ist träge und sogar
auch irgendwann vielleicht sogar krank
macht ne also so würde er akzeptieren
geistige Lust intellektuelle Lust
vielleicht auch moralische Lust hurra
also Lust an Werten
erkenntnisbildung solche Dinge
vielleicht auch
kulturelle Genüsse ja wenn wir einen
schönen Konzert uns befinden und dadurch
irgendwie inspiriert werden wenn wir
Museum unterwegs sind die klassischen
bildungsgüter rein dann haben wir auch
Lust Empfindungen aber es ist eine
geistige Lust und keine bloß tierische
Lust auch wenn ich diese unterscheiden
nicht so ganz
helfen finde bloß tierische Gelüste aber
so ist die Argumentation und darüber
wollen wir natürlich gleich ganz
kritisch aber natürlich auch ganz fair
diskutieren
jetzt haben wir uns mit dem
Utilitarismus natürlich nur ganz kurz
und oberflächlich auseinandergesetzt all
das Gute wird jetzt hier am Ende eben
doch über Werte über Wert Bewusstsein
Wert Erkenntnis mal wieder reingeholt
natürlich kann man sie jetzt fragen was
ist jetzt denn hier ein nicht bloß
tierisches Gelüsten sein geistiges
gelöst also müsste um höhere geistige
Werte gehen
natürlich muss man sich fragen wie dann
wiederum gut sind oder ob man da nicht
schon wieder das Gute voraussetzt ne
Stichwort naturalistischer Fehlschluss
dann gibt's noch eine Bestimmung des
Guten im ardonologie also immer man kann
auch da möchte ich Ihnen eine kurze
Definition Vorlesen über das gute nur
schlaglichtig die Folien finden Sie
übrigens auf Ilias die können sich
herunterladen jetzt schon er sagt es ist
Immanuel kann sagt es ist überall nichts
in der Welt ja überhaupt auch außer
derselben zu denken wirklich was ohne
Einschränkung für gut könnte gehalten
werden also für absolut gut
als ein guter Wille also nichts mit
nutzen und nichts mit Glück und so Lust
Verstand Witz Urteilskraft und wie die
Talente des Geistes sonst heißen würden
oder Mut Entschlossenheit Beharrlichkeit
im Vorsatz sind als Eigenschaften des
Temperaments gut Tapferkeit er denkt er
vielleicht sogar auch ein Tugenden als
Eigenschaften des Temperaments sind ohne
Zweifel in manche Absicht gut und
wünschenswert aber Sie können auch
äußerst böse schädlich werden wenn der
Wille der von diesen Naturgaben
gebraucht machen soll und dessen
eigentümliche Beschaffenheit darum
Charakter heißt nicht gut ist also gut
ist allein ein guter Wille das heißt die
Motivation die hinter diesen Talenten
und Naturgaben wirklich ich kann
natürlich auch witzig sein und böse sein
das widerspricht sich nicht ja Sie
können sich alle diese Punkte hier
verstanden wird
als nächstes so denken dass sie zu etwas
Bösem führen oder dass sie böse
gebraucht werden sie können zum Beispiel
sich einen Bankräuber überlegen der eine
ganz ganz ganz hoch entwickelte
Urteilskraft hat der genau entscheiden
kann wann die Polizei Weg ist der
Prognosen erstellen kann der Situation
perfekt einschätzen kann hat eine sehr
gute entwickelte urteilskammer
er kann auch sehr beharrlich sein und
fünf Jahre lang den Plan eine Bank zu
überfallen anhängen er sehr beharrlicht
aber dennoch ist seine Verstandes Tugend
oder Charakter tun wenn man
Beharrlichkeit überhaupt als tund
ansehen möchte am Ende nicht intrinsisch
gut es geht um die Frage was ist im
Prinzip gut und nicht nur als Mittel zum
Zweck ne ähm das hat in seiner
Grundlegung zu Metapher das sieht nicht
bringe ihn noch ein Zitat was jetzt den
guten Willen als einzig gutes sehr
anschaulich werden ist er sagt nämlich
der gute Wille ist nicht durch das was
er bewirkt oder ausrichtet nicht durch
seine Tauglichkeit erreichen irgendeines
vorgesetzt
allein durch das wolle das heißt an sich
gut und für sich betrachtet ohne
Vergleich weit höher zu schätzen alles
was durch ihn zugunsten irgend
der Summe aller Neigung zustande
gebracht werden könnte ein Typ geht über
eins Zeit hier fünf Zeilen der Folie
gibt
natürlich sehen sie gleich es geht nicht
darum was der Wille wirkt oder
ausrichtet es geht nicht um die
Handlungsfolgen also nicht ein
utilitaristischer Ansatz sondern ein die
ontologischer Ansatz wenngleich durch
eine besondere Ungunst des Schicksals
oder durch kerkliche Ausstattung einer
stiefmütterlichen Natur ist diesen
Willen gänzlich an Vermögen fehlte seine
Absicht durchzusetzen wenn bei seiner
größten Bestrebung dennoch nichts von
ihm ausgerichtet würde und nur der gute
Wille freilich nicht etwa als bloßer
Wunsch Wunsch Wille dann merken sie
wieder wo das war auf dem Begriffs Netz
das war irgendwo in der Mitte oben zu
halten
nicht nur als Wunsch
nicht nur als bloßer Wunsch sondern als
die aufbetung aller Mittel so weit sind
unsere Gewalt sind das ist der Wille der
Wille ist die aufbetung aller Mittel zu
Weizen übrig Liebe so würde er dieser
Wille
wie ein Juwel doch für sich selbst
glänzen als etwas das seinen vollen Wert
in sich selbst hat also unabhängig ob
der Wille in der Handlung überführt
werden kann es geht nur um den Willen
die absichtintention oder die Maxime die
Nützlichkeit oder Fruchtlosigkeit dieses
Willens kann diese Werte wieder etwas
zusetzen noch abnehmen sie würde
gleichsam nur die Einfassung sein also
wie bei einem Juwel
sagen das worin der Juwel eingesetzt ist
zum Beispiel eine silbereinfassung
Juwelen sind häufig eingesetzt das
wissen sie wegen Dresden im Grünen
Gewölbe da sehen sie ganz viele solche
Juwelen die eingesetzt waren zumindest
bis vor kurzem und um ihn im gemeinen
Verkehr besser handhaben zu können oder
die Aufmerksamkeit wäre die noch nicht
genug Kenner sind auf sich zu ziehen
nicht aber um ihn kennenzulernen sein
wird zu bestimmen eine ganz interessante
interessantes Gleichnis ne also der gute
Wille gleich an Juwel und die Folgen
dieses guten Willens oder der Absicht
die können eintreten oder nicht das
haben wir nicht immer der Kraft wir
können tun was wir können wir können
alle Kräfte mobilisieren das sagte ja
nicht nur ein bloß Wunsch sondern die
aufbetung aller bitte wenn am Ende durch
Zufall unsere Handlung doch letztendlich
durchkreuzt wird unsere Absicht und wir
nicht zu dem Handlungsziel komme dann
Ende des an der an den Wert dieser
Intention dieses familiens nichts die
Folgen des Willens sind nur äußerlich
gewissermaßen wie die Einfassung eines
Juwels und auch darüber können wir jetzt
ganz kurz mal diskutieren
ja wir haben gesehen im man kann
verbindet den Begriff des Guten sehr
sehr stark auf den Willen bezogen auf
subjektive Zustände natürlich kann man
sich wieder fragen wie verhält sich das
dieser Versuch das Gute zu bestimmen zum
Problem ist naturalistischen Fehlschluss
das wäre eine eigene Überlegung wert
jetzt gehen wir natürlich noch als
dritte Position auf die tugenethik da
gehen wir auf Aristoteles ein auf seine
Ethik
und jetzt hatte hier eine interessante
Theorie des Guten oder des tugendhaften
übertriebene körperanstrengung ebenso
wie unzureichenden führen den Verlust
der leibeskraft dabei das gleichen
verdirbt dann Übermaßen
Speise und Trank die Gesundheit während
das rechte Maß sie hervorbringt stärkt
und erhält
ebenso ist es nun auch mit der Mäßigkeit
dem startmut und den anderen Tugenden
also ernährt sich den Begriff des Guten
über die Tugend angerechtigkeit hatten
wir schon als eine Tugend diskutiert wer
alles flieht und fürchtet und nichts
erträgt wird feige dagegen wir gar
nichts fürchtet mit dem alles angeht
toll das gleichen wird wir jede Lust
genießt
größtes Glück und sich keine enthält
zügellos wir aber jede Lust flieht wie
die sauerköpfigen Leute die
griesgrämigen Leute müssen jetzt
natürlich wieder das original
griechische parat haben da fehlt in eine
stumpf sind den Mäßigkeit und stark Wut
werden durch das zu viel und zu wenig
aufgehoben durch die rechte Mitte aber
erhalten also das ist jetzt ein Versuch
das Gute zu bestimmen anhand von
Charaktereigenschaften von abitus also
Haltungen gegenüber zum Beispiel von
Affekten oder
emotionalen zuständig man muss für
verschiedene Typen nicht für alle für
die Gerechtigkeit gilt das nicht dass
man da die rechte mit bilden muss aber
für die allermeisten Tugenden schon muss
man einfach die gesunde Mitte bestimmen
also gut ist die rechte Mitte das
Vermeiden von extrem und nicht nur die
arithmetische Mitte zu wir nehmen mal
die Extrempunkte und tu mal das
dividierens dann durch zwei sozusagen
und bekommt dann die arithmetische Mitte
raus sondern eben die rechte Mitte die
ausgeglichenen die ausbalancierte Mitte
so müssen sich das vorstellen wir lesen
noch ein Zitat es ist also die Tugend
ein Habitus des Wählens eine Haltung des
Wählens der die nach uns bemessene Mitte
hält und durch die Vernunft bestimmt
wird also die Vernunft kommt immer auch
noch ins Spiel nämlich wenn es um die
Urteilskraft geht dann die richtige
Mitte zu sehen und zwar so wie ein
kluger Mann oder Mensch er sagt man ich
habe jetzt Menschen übersetzt ihn zu
bestimmen fliegt die Mitte ist die
zwischen einem doppelten fehlerhaften
Habitus den Fehler des Übermaßes und den
Fehler des Mangels wir haben das gesehen
Tapferkeit ist das richtige Maß ähm auf
der einen Seite gibt es die Feigheit es
ist zu wenig darin nicht davon und auf
der anderen Seite gibt es die
Tollkühnheit der stirbt sich nicht ins
Gefecht oder in die Philosophie Klausur
ohne was gelernt zu haben das ist
genauso schlimm also ich kann die
Klausur Schwänzen dann bin ich praktisch
nach Aristoteles
zeige oder ich kann nichts lernen und
sagen ach das wird schon klappen ich
nehme hier noch ein Spickzettel mit und
dann bin ich nach Aristoteles tollkühn
und das ist beides nicht tugendtag
sondern die richtige Tugend um eine
Philosophie Klausur zu bestehen besteht
eben darin sich gut drauf vorzubereiten
den filocast bis zu machen hier
regelmäßig zu sein ohne ihn Tutorium zu
gehen
sie ist aber auch noch insofern Mitte
die Tugend als sie in den Affekten und
Handlung das mittlere findet und wählt
während der Fehler in dieser Beziehung
darin die Fehler darin bestehen dass das
rechte Maß nicht erreicht oder
überschritten deshalb ist die Tugend
nach ihre Substanzen ihren Wesen
Begriffen Mitte insofern sie aber das
Beste ist und alles gut aus ist sie ein
äußerstes und Ende das ist ganz wichtig
also Tugend darf jetzt hier nicht nur
als Mittelmaß verstanden werden wer
tugendhaft ist ist nicht ein
mittelmäßiger Charakter irgendwie so
halbgut halb schlecht halt so solange
sondern er ist der best Charakter weil
er eben das Mittelmaß der extremen
auszutarieren das ist ganz wichtig zum
Verständnis der Tugend bei aristotels
also Stichwort ist sie das rechte Maß
auch hier können wir jetzt noch ganz
kurz darüber diskutieren
und wir machen jetzt weiter man kann
jetzt hier bei Aristoteles noch ein
Stück weitergehen und ihn revitalisieren
und das macht der sogenannte ethische
Naturalismus und ich habe ihn schon
dieses Buch genannt für die paar food
natural goodness sie versteht sich als
eine Neo aristotelikerin also
aristoteles hat in der zweiten Hälfte
des 20 Jahrhunderts sehr viel
Aufmerksamkeit erfahren wenn es um die
praktische Philosophie geht wenn es um
die Bestimmung geht das gut ist deutsche
Übersetzung die Natur des Guten ist
nicht ganz treffen übersetzt eigentlich
müsste man es übersetzen natürliche
gutheiten ne die Natur des Guten und
irgendwie sagt ihm das Gute können wir
nur daran bemessen wenn wir die Liebe
bewiesen achten und zwar die Vollzüge
der Begriff des Lebens ist zentral ähm
und sie sagt wir können
defekte
feststellen wie zum Beispiel einen Tritt
tritt fahren der Welt Wolf der frisst
aber nicht an der jagdscheinigen das
heißt das was er tut entspricht nicht
seine Wesen seinen Wesen ist da besteht
darin zu jagen ist ein jagdier weil wenn
er das nicht tut nicht an der Jagd
teilnimmt dann ist es ein Defekt genauso
wie eine Biene die anderen Bienen die
Nektarquelle nicht mitteilt das heißt
die
handeln wenn man es Handeln überhaupt
nennen möchte die verhalten sich
entgegen ihre Wesens bestimmen und sie
spricht jetzt von Muster natürlich und
Normativität die nur würde jetzt
natürlich sofort sagen naturalistischer
Fehlschluss und sie fragt sich finden
wir dieselbe urteilsstruktur es geht mir
nicht es geht uns urteilen wenn wir das
Leben beurteilen und das moralisch gute
beurteilen finden wir dieselbe urteilt
wenn wir zunächst von Pflanzen und
Tieren zu Menschen übergehen und dann
von der Bewertung menschliche
Eigenschaften und Vollzüge im
Allgemeinen zu Bewertung des Willens in
besonderen also können wir über die
Wesens Bestimmung und über das
Feststellen von defekten natürlicher
Vollzüge am Ende auch was über
moralische Prädikate
moralische Verhältnisse und Phänomene
sagen so viel zum ethischen Naturalismus
ein riesen Thema momentan ich gebe jetzt
noch ein Ausblick auf die nächste
Sitzung sie ahnen schon heute hatten wir
es mit dem Guten zu tun nächste Sitzung
die nächsten beiden Sitzungen also
morgen und nächste Woche da geht es um
das moralisch böse oder auch um das
Schlechte wie unterscheidet sich das
bloß schlechte Form moralisch böse
wiefern ist das moralisch böse als
Defekt zu verstehen was ja für die
Partie so ein bisschen zu sagen scheint
und wie verhält sich das Böse zu unserer
Vernunft also ist das Böse das
unvernünftige oder kommt vielleicht
nicht doch auch ein bisschen im Bösen
unsere Vernunft
so viel dazu ich wünsche Ihnen noch eine
schönen restnachmittag bis zur nächsten
Sitzung